[music]
yeah yeah iwashita dazu
[applause]
[music]
ani
ah ah ah ah
Thank you very much for participating in the tax presentation.
I would like to reply to the dst representative
.
It will be overthrown and bring about many changes in the world. It
is truly worthy of being called a child of peace.
My name is Miyato, and this child is my child.
Between
the
swing and the bleeding stop, there is a child in Tokyo
That's right.
This child is the child born between me and the bleeding stop master, 3 Tenju. Now I'm
5 years old.
I'm spending it
and until now I
can see the actual urge to stop bleeding
I believe that the 3rd class is
hope for us, humanity  I'm in
[music] um [music]
Awakening
[music
] Ah,
I have a backpack
These are my clothes What's more
?
Don't move!
You look confused
I'll be trapped in a place like this.
No, it's a
tranquilizer gun.
If so, you
guys are still alive I
'm sure, what are
you doing?
If it doesn't hurt, you don't have to force yourself to say it I'm a
bad scene Cigar when I was a
professional
It doesn't matter when the battle starts
[MUSIC]
What is
it?
Is it a camp
?  The death penalty has become a slope
What time
is it?
However, everyone will live here for the
rest of their lives
ni
[music]
Yes, what are you saying?
Lecture
hey
I'm saying that girl is riding
[music]
Thank you
Stop binding
If you get any closer to her, I'm
sorry I just kicked my head
I
want to see the
second one That collar 2 The
name of the perverted bastard
Hit me
yeah yeah yeah
Is
there someone
behind me?
No matter what's wrong with your head,
chairman, shut up here
You know
what's going on with the bank?
And who attacked the
fugitive?  Do
you know what's going to happen?
It's
time for the scribblers to gather Hmmm
ha To the
Kudzu place
[music]
car
f 4 ej
[music]
What the
hell are you fishing for?
The collar you're wearing now This is not the collar you've been wearing until now
This collar has a bomb set in it to prevent killing each other.
First of all, this collar device is the
only restriction for everyone.
It has to be
ah ah ah
[music]
Don't come near here It's not the time for
idiots to pretend to be cool,
right?
I'm going to
survive today
tan According to the
records, the attack on the transport vehicle took place at 6:05pm
, and all the passengers died instantly.
That's right
, even
if it's something that makes you wonder,
who did it? Isn't it the work of extremists?
It is said that it will be done If
you kill 5
But is it necessary to go this far
?
It's not a big deal. There's one thing I
want you to investigate.
Could you please send me the list of prisoners killed or missing in the last 2 years yeah this is what i get yeah yeah yeah cocohana
[music]
[applause]
wh
[music]
uh
tan
car  The watch ear
problem has occurred. The
reason is that
the backup process will
be started soon.  A box like a stove The
wind blows out Likely
to use Wait
ren
goo
[music
] Not available
wh h
ana
I love them I know
I can't believe it
Cafe day
Come on come on e-mail e-
booker name please  Hmm
, this guy is from the prequel, Subaru, in front of
Yahata, open the door early
.
er I took you with me I
'm sorry web down hm
[music]
so far
kana here
katsuzuka
hey hey
ronan
[music]
when i
wh
ran n
[music]
asu he came
haru
ani
me
ni
[music]
aname
fufuii me ani good good good good
me
another power of the society gathered and monsters appeared
Seeing whether only doubts and memories are gathering will bring back the abominable memories of childhood
.